challenge you sometimes okay let's play
this guy
trigger and if i think it's uh yeah
someone reasonably strong
okay let's go knight f6 g6 this time
c4 okay let's go b6
now it's a string this should be seven i
think i played this position
uh recently against griezhook
in their sings masters and um
yeah in general played it many times and
i had
he had sort of decent results with it
anyways the way he played is not really
ambitious obviously so he allows
everything
including c5
yeah so now i guess it's all about
knight d4 coming one day
or d5 so let's say now we can just go
knight d4
if we want or we can go g5 okay let's go
g5 i guess
so he takes once again we can start by
playing 94 actually
maybe there is no need to let's just
take
so the basic idea in insults lions is
takes
what he actually was 94
okay let's go 94 forget about the basic
idea
it was anyway contradicting
what i'm about to do
um so i can take on c3 take on f3
he will have bad structure
i'll be slightly better or i can just go
e5
and he goes e3 i think it's also
slightly better
yeah i don't know somehow i like this is
this line more to be honest
so he'll probably take with the bishop
we take up three
he'll probably just take
yeah i actually don't know why i decided
to allow him this uh
this exposition yeah exactly but i just
thought it's very good for black i don't
need to avoid this
yeah i still think so actually okay
i think at some point i will have to
remove the knight from d4
do we worry down towards the trade
if princess now i think i can go knight
five
yeah so by some miracle he's actually
holding so after
quintex d3 he has rook d2 red
and if i take consistent angle c4 he has
a
yeah he has rook d2 as well
although this is less convincing
actually
so i can also go c for now
then i think he takes on g7
uh
okay i guess i see cool line so let's go
c4
yeah so this is exactly the line i'm
talking about so
can it actually work if it does it's
actually cool
so what i'm talking about is i go quintx
d3
he takes on d3 i go c takes d3 rook
takes c8
i go g takes e2 rook takes date king
takes g7 resigns now
okay let's give it a shot
it actually seems to work but if it does
work it's just
i mean it's really nice
so the point is that after rook takes
eight if i take on say it he's
sort of fine he goes rook to 2 and he's
in time to
collect the disrepair and he's just
slightly worse
yeah but we go d take c2 yeah d take c2
rook takes d8 king takes g7 resigns
right once again
yeah seems correct wow
this is actually cool
yeah thanks for the game